Data, a collection
of information
in its most basic form.
Its potential to
change the way we
see ourselves, our
world, and our future.
But only if it's open.
Made available to access,
analyze, and inform action.
Open data is information
collected by government,
business, and organizations.
Added together and
made anonymous,
it's safe to be released.
To use, reuse, and distribute.
You already know it as things
like geospatial data, weather
data, and government
census data.
You can use open data to
simply get from A to B.
Or you can use open data for
more far reaching reasons,
like making government
more transparent,
helping voters,
journalists, and politicians
to better understand.
And improve our society.
Open data crowdsources
expertise, pulling information
from all around the world, to
help researchers fight disease,
and relief workers
coordinate disaster response.
Open data drives
innovation helping
build new business and
more strategic investment.
Creating new jobs,
even new industries,
and stronger economies.
We live in an increasingly
connected world.
Right now we've opened only
a fraction of the data that
could benefit us.
Just as the world transformed
with the birth of the internet,
imagine the potential
of opening up more data.
Allowing us to see our
world from new perspectives.
Driving innovation
education and discovery.
Open data.
Open potential.